would you have you but you can't go back
and fight anymore right well no I would
not right mmm but you yeah you with it
but if you took that stuff now you
definitely come in you couldn't maybe
I'll do Bellator can fight in UFC though
right do you feel sometimes like that
vile like that you had an aggression at
that time that's not the same now like a
son yeah cuz I've never seen in your
face but I could even imagine you like I
couldn't imagine you as if I don't I
don't mean that any offense you know I
don't fans take and yeah a lot of people
can't like I was watching the fight
Saturday my girls families in town
they're staying with us and watch some
fights in her grandma's like I can't
believe people do this and then some was
like we know Brett in fact she's like no
and she's like why this goofball and
then we had to bring up highlight she's
like what and I was watching like oh
it's a different dude that's a different
game that's cool though man that's great
this I mean it way that's cool just to
go to different do you be able to take
on different things and you know and uh
and stick to them that must've been the
heart was it so hard to just keep
training and that kind of stuff I love
the Train I still love the Train but it
was just it was so excuse stressful and
scary for me yeah stressful and scary
and where there's some animals out there
and that sport I mean there's no savages
yes ma'am yes oh yeah god
phenomenal fighters struggling scares me
bro me too
scares me a lot and I get scared of that
having to really fight somebody like I
can fight somebody that I could beat up
you know yeah but to really fight
somebody man and after really yeah it's
not gonna be easy
there was no easy fight no swords all
good no hatchets brother dude did
anybody ever try to like sneak anything
in their waistband like you couldn't do
anything I never like a blood sport like
put salt Meyers some like crunch it up
like Chong Li yeah glass up your
knuckles or something no yeah man I
wouldn't she
I would [ __ ] put some cinnamon
between my fingers right there something
more you know I would do something you
know we're hot a little bit of pepper
right there my knuckle oh wow you know
that's gonna help they kick it up a
little if you get pepper in one of
somebody's eyes then one odd then you're
fighting like a 100
in the eye and they give you a warning
yeah but that poke they you know that
pepper they might not see it it's so
small you know or glitter even the
glitter they'd see cuz you ever if you
miss the eye you're gonna get it on the
cheek and they're gonna see that I don't
know I got to think of some more
strategies but I wouldn't be the best
fighter though it's not for everyone
watching I would be the fear bear that
would be my fighter name there'd be the
key Rat King bro King dude some guy
would just take me can steal is it
really it's a steel cage with rubber
over it hardens Foster's draught doing
draught [ __ ] when up on the draft down
rafts on a raft dude and if you get you
know I'm saying if you start especially
if you if you trail along a giraffe's
neck
guess what's at the top a [ __ ] head
you need to get burned you're gonna get
your head butted dude but how they have
horns here's a little factory - I
struggle sometimes with spelling as a
kid you really I could see that not
anymore though well you're the mullet
so um but I used to think giraffe was de
RAF it talks about 23 no drafts a black
dude bro I know it's a real story I
thought it was a de RAF fight you public
education they let me slide our rafts no
ever said anything look at them for
coupons over their imports is a crazy
kübra I just got this Bolden retriever
right here I got all the [ __ ] mammals
you got those de RAF the longest until
my friend Shankar when he's the educated
man went you know it starts with the G
Reilly shut the [ __ ] up he was I swear I
have a college education two degrees no
one ever said [ __ ] do that a kid in our
town named robitussin Hearns this black
dude that's a great name it was
beautiful eye doctor um nope I think he
actually did enough work in a medical
facility though but I don't know in what
fast
ya know but this is a long time ago
robitussin mr. Roberto yeah Robi they
called him ro bro
yeah Robi robro ro yeah people probably
call him row row Oklahoma oboe
we had a boy named dressed to kill in
our town and he uh well we're church
socks all the time and the crazy part is
he ended up going to jail for murder
damn I got two holes I got two holes and
tan and a positive attitude and I'll use
my feet if I have if I go limp just wake
me up by bust oh dude
well they're gonna see this and you're
screwed corporate now I am corporate now
you're corporate it's fun though it was
fun yeah it's a privilege I walk I
finally ever gone before you've done
this before I find the red carpet very
very awkward it's hot in stores the
women doll up shop over here smile put a
fist stop nope nope nope nope it's a
walnut the Golden Globes I'm gonna put a
fist up and make zero then yeah well
you're good you you doll up cuz you you
like fashion well you check so you you
big you big man check and I think like
if did you look like [ __ ] on the red
carpet
well hold on stylist hold on I'll get
normal to Vince and I bought a black
suit Oh Vince can you get a suit I
didn't I wasn't I didn't look like a
piece of coral it wasn't tailor like a
piece of fire coral the way you do okay
you know you look like an uber driver
dude I really resent Zack like an uber
girls wearing and it causes the Brian
count but I was super driver I was
wearing expensive pair I was like
wearing an expensive theory suit of
course I got 13 what well you have any
suits because you guys I got it at a
sample sale
oh no yeah I did that means once the
common projects you [ __ ] no no there
was a stain on the pants there was a
stain on the butt that black suit no it
was blue blue and the white color in
their shirt a black undershirt not bad I
pulled it off
and then I had a blue I had my slide
belt I put on my slide belt one of our
sponsors oh nice and I put the one on it
says fire in the kid and then I had my
common projects I'm not mad that I was
looking adorable ladies - I'm not gonna
lie to you I hope so not really but they
were talking
the thing is some dudes right hit on you
too though well no I had to stand there
have you ever been up front sir this I
have signs nothing but you've never been
on your own spin off like you never
liked the lead I was no I'm what on
inside Schwartz which was one and also
uh fat actress but this is a good that
was one in a while but that wasn't your
show right I was I was a series regular
but this is a little different yeah this
is a big that there's something I don't
know if I enjoy anything more than a
meal and a good sign no I wasn't gonna
say that
I said have you've changed bro yeah hold
on you're just different conversation
yeah I guess a little boring I've gotten
your more I [ __ ] his podcast going
searching for something I told you a
story that went nowhere before we
started the one of the worst stories
over in my life and he gave us a
four-hour long goat story that's how
long ago story and then now you're
talking about I just like a nice meal
and a conversation yeah and then I say
dick suck and you look at me like I'm
some eye cream I'm like really like how
do you sir I'm on ABC now oh my god Oh
would they ever say anything [ __ ]
what I don't know but I'll come back to
the podcast and you stand a palette I
disagree you know what I guarantee if
they're like Brian we need you stop
talking about sucking dick right right
your jig gnarled up eared friend okay we
need you to stop you come on like bro
listen I'm not telling you how to talk
today we could not reach dicks anymore
on the show it would help me out a lot
yeah can you imagine no thanks I'll just
cut the nice thing about not being just
an actor is I'll come back to my podcast
and I'll do stand-up thank you by the
way everybody for ice we sold out Talia
hall in two days I can't believe that
dang a third show welcome don't I'm not
- I'm not doing three shows for free no
I don't know hey don't I'm not doing
three first to me listen I read oh no no
no no show Thursday I do
oh okay three the day oh dude I don't we
don't do I thought we were talking about
we don't down
without the college I shouldn't have let
you do that nope you [ __ ] me but you
had lost my voice you had to learn cuz
you're an athlete so you would have
fought you would have forced yourself
lost your voice mm-hmm
lost your voice that's uh people don't
realize that that's over three hours of
comedy in one night not easy and you're
shouting and I'm grievin yeah
and meeting greets it says another hour
about six hours that's a barrel blast